hair stylists various technicians that
are involved with Albert Nobbs next we
have harry potter and the deathly
hallows part 2 please welcome to the
stage Nick Dudman Nick is credited as
special effects and it's jones us today
from London England where he is working
on the completion of the makeup and
hairstyling for the warner brothers
studio tour that's going to be a great
place to see because it's going to be on
the lot where Harry Potter was filmed
and so they'll have a lot of the the
stages and different areas for people to
see in next time you're on London this
is the first oscar nomination for Nick
his other awards include eight BAFTA
Award nominations for harry potter and
the deathly hallows part one and two
Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire
harry potter and the prisoner of azkaban
harry potter and the chamber of secrets
Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone
plus Batman and the fifth element for
which he won a BAFTA
please welcome Amanda night amanda is
credited as the makeup designer Amanda
joins us from London England where she's
working on the completion of the makeup
and hairstyling for the warner brothers
studio tour also and we'll be starting
fast & furious 6 this is the first oscar
nomination for a man to her her other
awards include five BAFTA Award
nominations for harry potter deathly
hallows part 2 harry potter and the
deathly hallows part one Harry Potter
and the Goblet of Fire harry potter and
the prisoner of ice pond harry potter
and the sorcerer's stone and she won one
Hollywood makeup artist and hairstylist
Guild Award for harry potter and the
chamber of secrets also please welcome
Lisa Tomlin Lisa Tomblin is credited as
hair designer and lisa joins us from
London England where she is presently
working on the completion of makeup and
hairstyling for the warner brothers
studio tour and also will soon be
starting on Fast & Furious 6 this is the
first oscar nomination for lisa her
other awards include to bafta awards for
harry potter and the deathly hallows
part 2 and harry potter and deathly
hallows part one very potter and the
deathly hallows part 2 was filmed in
England so
this was a project that went on for how
many years Nick ten years ten years okay
so you and Amanda were involved in in
all of the films yes we were involved in
all of them and then Lisa joined sort of
little later on but we we've never had
parole that way well that's great I
think we could open the curtain and
let's take a look at some of the clips
that we have here now this was a great
accomplishment you you if you have seen
all the Harry Potters you know that some
of these characters went all the way
through you know that that that the the
kids grew up you in fact you even saw
the kids who were grown up and had kids
at the very end of this last one in the
very first film we saw some of these
characters that were in the bank these I
thought were just outstanding you want
to tell us a little bit about what was
involved with some of this yeah well on
the very first Harry Potter I was first
approached to discuss the Gringotts Bank
sequence because I alem had done a
digital Goblin test and I was basically
shown that and asked if I could do it
for real because digitally it was going
to cost too much money and I said yes I
me now you say that again Reginald was
going to work come too much money yes it
was a large amount of money but then I
realized that these people were prepared
to spend a large amount of money on
makeup so that was okay we basically
decided we would attempt to do the leap
goblins in the very first picture in
silicon which at that time was very iffy
and you know it was a scary thing to
attempt to do so we did actually have
backups
where we could run we'd run foam in the
molds if we had to and there are a
couple of foam goblins as well and a
load of background heads that were just
pull on silicon heads we got away with
it one of my crew pulled spiteri has
been working on Potter for 10 years with
me he really sort of trouble shot how to
get the silicon to behave enough for us
to get away with it but when we came
back in 7 part 2 10 years later we in
that process you know suddenly silicon
is easy it's straightforward it you know
if so many people are using it and it
just looks better and it's great stuff
so we decided we would do everything in
platte gel and we also made the decision
that any goblin would be a close-up
goblin this did get changed slightly so
we did have some background heads but we
had around 40 prosthetic characters and
every single one was sculpted as an
individual character from life cast
every single one had nothing in common
with anything else so we took we made
our own wig blocks for each character we
made our own wigs in house and we
produced all the pieces we had no lace
eyebrows everything was punched for
every single day and we just kept
tweaking this picture up here is Warwick
Davis playing Griphook on the very first
day of shooting that character we were
in Wales and we had a we'd race to get
him ready originally had a goatee beard
and all sorts of things and we found
that the thing with Potter unlike a lot
of movies is that your producer can come
up and go hey that's fantastic that
little line there so weary sculpted the
homemaker and then we restarted it again
the idea being that you just refined and
just because you've shot on something
and you thought that's not bad but oh
hang on if we could only do that little
bit more we were able to do that so
actually in this picture Griphook sculpt
is really quite crude compared to later
on and in fact this scene was never in
the film so it didn't matter anyway we
see the next clip please
it's still me I've lost some weight yeah
this was actually this was fun because
I've worked a lot with little people
over the years because I've kind of done
a lot of genre movies where they call
little people into play parts and this
this is a lady her name's Diane and she
is what do you reckon that's all she's
one of the tiniest little people I've
ever seen and she was a chain-smoking
grumpy miserable piece of work she was
lovely but she had yeah here she is no
she did have a mouth on it but it was
great because every single character got
to be developed you know you could treat
every single one that as possibly a
close-up goblin who's going to be used
more and more because when we shot the
sequence we then went back over the
following year doing old pickups and
inserts and things so you never knew
when you actually shot main sequence how
many pieces you need for any one of
these characters because you didn't know
which ones would be popular next
Cleverly's I think you're sitting on
your microphone no you're not you're
gonna we're going to be sharing some
mics have mine hello um well a lot of
facial hair was on this film Hagrid I
think we had the two most naughtiest
actors to stick bids on that we could
possibly have Robbie Coltrane and
Michael Gambon were dreadful with their
beards and they would take them off at
lunch time without me knowing and we
actually had over Dumbledore's did we
used to make a silk sort of wrap to go
over it at lunchtime which he think he
thought it was hilarious to fill out
with chips and things like that at lunch
so we we had our hands full with these
actors there was a lot of facial hair on
there we had they kept his very busy and
Lisa there was a lot of facial hair but
there had to be very few people other
than maybe some of the kids who didn't
have wigs on yeah we have a massive
amount of wigs in actual fact his is the
only week that is hasn't got a lace
front because he sweats a lot Robbie and
he doesn't really like lace so I left
that mitt to Amanda yeah he had to do
him very very quickly doesn't like being
in the chair 20 minutes between us to
get him reading michael gambon you'd
you'd get him ready and he didn't wear
hat in the last scene so they obviously
had to be perfect and then he'd stick
his own hat and glasses on and walk out
yes our they're not looking at that here
they are actually now also i'm going to
expect that looking at the clothes and
looking at the size of him perspiration
wasn't a problem was it welcome it was a
nightmare to keep that badge on it
really was a miracle it did actually and
michael gambon did actually come off in
one thing they called me in at the end
when they said cut he was dan was
actually holding his beard well it's
certainly one way to ensure the rap is
we see the next clip please oh we've got
their breakdown lots of the last film
was more about the characters that we've
created over the ten years was more
about destroying them and they had this
huge war and we had to destroy them
completely and so there was blood and
guts and goodness knows what else on all
of their nearly all of the cost I think
there's about one hundred and sixty two
of them so when we won't go through them
all by name but there was there was a
lot next clip please we've got um Rupert
and his disguise here having been known
always as the ginger one it was quite
tricky to make a disguise for him and
again with his facial expression
back to the facial hair back to a beard
again and he's why he is such a fabulous
actor in that part is his facial
expressions which is the worst thing
possible for us with a beard the moment
he laughed we had to keep everyone away
from him not telling him jokes because
he'd laugh and it all the sides but it
will pop out and okay next clip please
now this is an unusual one because this
was a this was sort of a a wonderful
melding of prosthetics and CGI can you
tell us a little bit about that yes i
can i'll just look firmly at mark kuliah
who's sitting over there because this is
his makeup and marks nominated for the
Iron Lady but if there were more spaces
on the ticket mark I'm sure would be
sitting up here for this film as well
over ten years his contribution to Harry
Potter is very significant that said
this is us and Mark who was um know what
we did here we had some concept art on
the fourth film I think that a guy
called robles had done of Voldemort
turning from a sort of withered fetus
thing that we had built into ray Fiennes
and that artwork kind of drove where we
started from the main thing that was
found out when we were very first
testing this was if he's covered in
veins all over and he's going to be sort
of airbrushed it takes forever and it
was marker came up with this idea of
making everything as transfer tattoos so
we basically mapped an airbrush makeup
out flat and then cut it into lots of
bits and then had it printed so that we
could then put the veins on as a tattoo
layer every day which meant that the
continuity theoretically would be
perfect so and that Harv to the makeup
time that alone was a very very clever
idea and it worked a treat he's got brow
pieces just literally to get rid of his
eyebrows he was really good Rafe he
agreed to shave his head which
made life fantastic there was one
occasion I think it was only one day
mark can correct me where we had to put
a ball cap on him because he had been
doing something else and he couldn't
shave his head but that made life you
know much much easier for us the
decision to lose the nose came from the
producer David Heyman because he kept
going back to the book and it says all
he's got this flat face and snake-like
face can you do anything and so we had
to prove to him that if you build out
anybody's face enough to get rid of the
nose they start looking like a rodent
which wasn't going to be good and I mean
I think you know all of us in my
department we are actually contrary to
popular belief very fond of CG digital
work because occasionally something
comes up where you know damn well that
the way to do this properly is digitally
and we basically took his life cast
chiseled the nose off sculpted umpteen
versions of a flat nose showed them to
him and said well which one do you want
and they scanned it did a test and the
test was amazing and it changes him so
completely so it was a wonderful you
know moment tonight actually it was a
perfect amalgam of digital and
traditional make up one of those one of
those places where it it really really
serves a purpose that it couldn't be
done by makeup maybe a plastic surgeon
but not that makeup it's tough to lose
the nose all right let's give a round of
applause to these nominees and let's
take a look at this film leben and see a
little more of this